on the paint on joyride no wait not
paint i'm going to go in on the uh i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna shoot for
three pointers what's the term oh my god
uh not not paint not black face i'm
gonna go uh
uh uh dribble uh prime minister trudeau
shoe polish [ __ ]
oh no
they're too late
joy reid compared kyle rittenhouse's
crying on the stand to brett kavanaugh
saying that both were fake all right
let's go so it's car written house trial
it reminded a lot of people of something
something i just can't remember what it
was oh so she wears the wig in her house
one tooth is trying to escape tears
turned out to be more powerful
than the tears of christine blasey ford
which were the tears of an alleged
victim
but in america there's a thing
about both white vigilantism
and white tears
particularly
male white tears yeah there's an l in
there really white tears in general
because that's what carrots are right
they carry out and then as soon as you
get caught you're carrying right now